enter
president backup software corporation
what is on the board to keep on overseas members
of the board members of the faculty
bride parents and gray day of the many
congratulations the people
with like to tell you
he builds together my experience is
the ceremony marks the end of  and
probably also hart chapter in new life
the door to new life is opening the
exciting and inspiring the german
reiter hermann hesse had some other words
intentional situation in life than like
them and continue in may native language
hermann hesse wrote every beginning has
a magic in it  who protects us and
who helps us to live
hermann hesse world in obedience duels
at the magic predecessor einhellinger
stellv these words have hesse
inspired me when i graduated in physics at the age of 24
it was the year
1978 rosberg was divided into 1 teams the world was
divided into  east and west levels the
willow tinto is a west
it was the time of the cold war in
the grapes of s  orrow i
grew up in east germany in the gdr
the then unfree part of my
home country in a dictatorship group in
east germany in the chill out of my
country people were oppressed and
monitored the presses each other states by
mistake political opponents were
persecuted politicians dissident the
government of the gdr had  fear that the
people would run away to freedom which
is german government where it expanded
pippo well fliethe peace
that's why she
built the berlin wall it was made of concrete and stole
the model the berlin wall along with
concrete we discovered in the
attempt she was overcome  wanting was
arrested or shot
some coaching so before new year's eve
from bulkheads this wall right through
berlin divided a people and they divided
families my family was also divided
the world cup berlin in helped the willow
the game is waiting formally may company
level so the willow mine
i had my first job after
graduating  s physicist and applauded job at the
academy of sciences in east berlin
at college it was when it is
the academy of sciences in berlin i
lived near the berlin wall
a lift in every berlingo on the
way home from my institute i went up it
every day  to work that every day
on my way home for my institute
behind it lay west berlin freedom
like a medley west berlin freedom and
every day when i was very
close to the wall i had to
turn off at the last moment to my apartment way
that had my apartment
every  day had
to turn right before freedom happy day to turn the way for freedom atlas minute
how many times have i thought that i
can't stand
it was really frustrating i was
n't a dissident
i didn't run into the wall
the run up a few quite as well  but
i didn't deny it either, because
i didn't want to bloom only helpers
own the new existence of wanted
to myself die berliner maue  r limited
my options for berlin where they
with majo penalties they literally stood in my way
naturally studio
but one thing that this wall has
n’t managed to be higher in all these years elvis
fans in wolfsburg could the
thuringian ursaurier is my accident impulse to set my own
inner limits
les mads my personality
my fantasy my longings all of that
could not be limited by bans and coercion
personal team imagination dreams and
desire s political soccer can
rule limit for a while
then came the year 1989
because game ninety nine all over
europe the common will to freedom had
incredible power  getting free the
thing for friedemann is in cottbus
is in poland hungary in slovakia and
also in
the gdr hundreds of thousands dared to take to the streets in
poland in hungary decision-maker slovakia
[music
] people demonstrated and brought down
the wall
the piper demonstrated
what many  people not for possible
I hadn't held it either,
it became a reality something with many
people including the third htg posco
became reality where there used to be a dark
wall, a door suddenly opens
there where it was also for me the
moment came to step through for
rent for a minute  came thurk for otto
i no longer have to turn at the last moment
before freedom a hardness turner
wave race minute i could cross that
boundary and go into the open but
said to cross the bode and venture art
in the great wide open these
months 33 years ago  i have personally
experienced that it doesn't have to stay the way it
is
this time the experience is almost 100 after
in haste stay away
this experience dear graduates
i would like to give you my
first thoughts
for your future of the experience building it's almost dead for your future
was  seems firmly attached and unchangeable
that can change
can change and on a large scale
and on a large scale as well as on a small scale applies in
some / 10
every change begins in the mind hosted
exchange beginning sense means
my parents generation had to
learn the extremely painful my parents
generation of the body in speedway my parents generation of the body in speedway my
father and my mother were born in 1926 and
28 my father in morocco in 92 96
when they so  were old like most
of you here today were the
break with civilization the shoa and the
second world war just over
it ends my country germany had brought
unimaginable suffering to europe and the
world micron germany which
probably would have been
victors and defeated for a long time
implacably  would face
moving sends deficits silly harry
thinks erik seidel from the manager is but
instead europe overcame
centuries of conflict james ensor
conflict a peace order was created that depends on
common ground instead of apparent
national strength psv or base
values and special thanks always in all d
scussions and
setbacks in the meantime i am
firmly convinced the
europeans are fortunately united
it at tori discussions a temple 6 1
formally supplied like european society
for the better
also
shows the relationship between germans and americans how friends from former
wartime enemies where and
relationship between german center
american states of forward 1 1 m/s can
become fans very significantly
[applause]
and
george marshall's plan, which he announced
here in 1947 at 1 x commerce with speech
porsche competition in 97 in
displays
[applause]
the transatlantic  partnership with
our values of democracy and human
rights has already given us a perio
of over 70 years of peace and p
osperity from which all sides
benefit with
ransatlantic partnership based on value
sexkino christian human rights issue that
s 11 parity on benefit to which is
love  stands from the 17th
and today  an today it won't be
long then the
politicians of my
generation will no longer be the subject of the
exercise in leadership course but
at most will be part of again ship in
history of exercise in leadership
program ruby the wolf in leadership in histo
y love has class 2009 10 have
classic solving means your generation
will face the
challenges of the twenty-first
century generation in the coming decades,
whereby facebook challenges of the twenty
first in the coming of the kids they are
among those who will
lead
us into the future arango's song endangers us in the future
protectionism and trade conflicts
free world trade and
thus the basis of our
prosperity digitization covers all areas of
life digital
transformation russells oversize wars
and terrorism lead to flight and expulsion
go a terrorist song
displacement
information climate change threatens d  he natural livelihoods
climate change processes
swat valley planets natural resources
he and the resulting crises
are man-made
andrews elting price is on itunes
so we can and must do everything
humanly possible to really get a grip on this
challenge to humanity
africa and must  do
[applause] that's
still possible hits of the possible
but everyone has to
do their part
energy was the mass player bad and
i say that self-critically become
better than sales manager appear money
better
i will therefore do everything in my power to
ensure that germany
country will
achieve the goal of climate neutrality in 2050
everything to enjoy the german
village of climate treaty at 25 c
[laughter]
changes for the better are possible
if we tackle them together
changes for the better a possible
politician going it alone will
not succeed futurecare  italian
naked choke matsc  h and so this is my
second thought to you the second
thoughts on to share with a fist
several we have to
think and act multilaterally city unilaterally modern waves enking
action safety mode ledger was in june
[applause]
global city national global
snacking
[applause]
cosmopolitan city isolationist
outlook live nation is
together instead of alone in china
tour advice to all those who prefer so
graduates
will have very different opportunities in the future
than disinfecting my generation uk credit
suisse my generation
probably has a
lot more smartphones  more computing power than the
ibm mainframe computer replicated by the soviet union
that i was
able to use for my dissertation in the gdr in 1986
graduation smartphone blizzcon stream
processing power corp ibm mainframe
company in 16
today we use artificial
intelligence to search millions of
images for symptoms of diseases
search
death  ay we used artificial intelligence
for example to say to millions images
for systems on this and, for example
, to be able to diagnose cancer better
or to improve your own
cancer in the
future, empathetic robots could
help doctors and nurses to concentrate on the
individual needs of individual patients
in future and  assessing the body talk
talk talk wettest people to the
individual sessions we can't even
foresee which applications are possible
with a connoisseur's eye today with the patients
with but the opportunities that come with
it are truly breathtaking
however the opportunities brings has
july price taking dear graduates it
lies  essentially up to you how we use
these opportunities we classes 1 teams
is opportunities mobile from that brad
pitt you will be the ones to help
decide how our way of
working communicating moving
we will develop our whole way of living
once  you will be draft in deeside in
harburg communicator soon in lithuania
meat multiple as chancellor
i often have to ask myself am i doing the
right thing is done chance hopes after
chinas myself doing the rising am i
doing something because it is right or just because
it is possible
once doing  something because it is
right from the playback as it is possible
you should keep asking yourself
that is his thing youtube went
out and is that is my third thought
for you today a nice one
the charity day we set the rules
of technology or  does the technology determine
our coexistence will angel russo
technology technology dictateam high
interest
[music]
do we focus on people with
their dignity and in all their facets
the paradise pieper as
interviewers human dignity and over
manifests or do we only see
the data source for the customers that  monitoring
obtained driessen amélie consumers data
service object on syrias that are
difficult questions this question
i have learned that
answers can also be found for difficult questions
because we always see the
world through the eyes of the other
we can find green on steven chu the
fixed costs trio the world is
open to details
if the respect before
[applause  ]
[applause]
if the respect for the history of the
tradition of the religion and the identity
others have respect but people's
history edition
if we stand firmly by our
inalienable values and act e
actly according to having to compete in aliens and i
we have to compete in all the pressure to make decis
ons  don't always
follow our first impulses show up and where it gets
stuck and up almost in the positive very
special to make a decision but in
between
but in between pause for a moment
be silent thinking take a break
at the stage stores inc of
course that takes courage
grumpy patrick scales above all needs
it abe truthfulness towards others  r
on course encrypt institute aris
and perhaps most importantly towards
ourselves at
da has it would have to
[music]
[applause]
where better to
start than right here in this
place where so many young people from
all over the world are under the motto  learning the truth
together researching and discussing the questions of
our time on the
maxim that means that we don't lie
truths and truths don't lie
patrick reimers not to describe this is
to choose life
[laughter]
[applause]
it means that we don't abuse
as ours  accept normality
advisors motto except for coming
sessa ti what but could rather use solvents and
ab what could
prevent us
red dot de dios christophe bott stop us
from doing bad again there are walls
when you like the harvest is walls in
the heads out of ignorance  and
narrow-mindedness we are people's means
josef ignorance an event they happen
between members of a
family  kocsis between family members
as well as between social
groups skin-colored people religions speedweek
wolski preventing is from invision in
the world in which together
whether it succeeds is up to us therefore love
engraved my fourth thought place for
youtube views ticking culprit is it
bear in mind nothing is of
course nothing  can be taken
for around in our individual
freedoms are not self-evident
also interview liberty sun place
democracy is not self-evident
democracy is not something we can take
fairground in peace
unfortunately is not peas and prosperity either
because unfortunately that is parrot
but if we break down the walls  tearing us
down every breaking wave since
hemmers in when we go into the open and
new beginnings have been every step out in the open had karadzic embrace new beginnings then
everything is possible everything is possible
[applause]
walls can collapse wolfskin
collapse dictatorships can  n disappear
dictate ships knowledge p you can
stop
global warming ricken holt global roaming
we can beat hunger
recreation we can get diseases out of fleets
we can all away diseases
we can give people and especially
girls access to education ricken gpt special girls
access to education  we can
we can fight the causes of flight and
expulsion where i in fight
the causes of displacement infos
migration all of that we can do we can do
[applause]
let's not ask first what
doesn't work and what has always been like that,
ask first what  let's go and look
for what has never been done like this
last used at ascot is a
processing of gods own way last at
ask what is possible and looking things
that have never been like but before
i used exactly these words in 2005
in my first  government declaration as the
newly elected federal chancellor of the
federal republic of germany as the first
woman in this office in the german
bundestag told the german parliament
it is exactly potter set the bundestag
with german parliament in tucson in five
us policy statement on the public
service office
and with these words i would like to give
you my fifth
thoughts too says aaron presley the  world to share
with let's surprise ourselves with what's
possible head of sales at schering
what is possible let's surprise ourselves
with what we could
if you had prices service at schering
maria kemper on in my own
life it was the fall of the berlin wall that made
it happen to me before now  almost 30 years allowed
to go into the open
lifepr berlin where i left my
work as a scientist behind me
and went into politics
pulev workers and is behind me and and
politics that was exciting and full of
magic of exciting a medical time
as well as for  your life
will be exciting and full of magic that it will be your
life as well as exciting a magic
but i also had moments of doubt
and concern with the user
experience on board we all knew at the time what
beckoned behind us but not what
lay ahead for the time we knew what
lady heim the hot rod whitehead
maybe it's all about you
joy about today a
little bit like flexstrom youtube as my
sixth experience i can therefore
also tell you
to 6 the moment of openness is also
a moment of risk
vernon trained turks letting go of the
old
is part of a new beginning as a single on
the  youth is part of a new beginning
there is no beginning without an end and
no day without night only david knight
no life without death only live
our whole life consists of the
difference of the difference between
the beginning and the blv live consists
of defense space  between beginning and
ending what lies in between
we call life and experience
it's what lies in between the recall
live experience
ic  h believe that we always have to be
ready to end things in order
to feel the magic of the beginning and to
really use opportunities.
rhyme in time again we need to
be prepared to bringing things to enter
the magic of new beginnings developer
best of opportunities supplies
that was  my experience during my studies as a
model and young people in science
so you are and it is in
politics a ccs mother experience in
politics
and who knows what follows for me after my life
as a politician a tournament live
wolbring automatic it is completely
open is complex
only one thing is clear only one thing is clear there will be
something different and new until the beginning of
the 52
an event of nothing has today as it
is
[laughter]
[applause]
ok
jumps the steady take action in the
outline often painted level global world
cups  went josef sellmer doing something
the courses des reit simply because it's
possible don't forget that freedom is
ne was something that can be taken a  new
beginning
[music]
[applause]